>> DANILATOS: Hello everyone. Yeah. So my
name is Daniel, I work with GWT on the Google
Wave Client in Sydney. So today, I'd like
to share with you some of the best practices
we've found have served us well over time
with respect to writing reliable testable
GWT applications. It used to be that it was
hard for us to write with unit tests. But
by applying some of the ideas I'm going to
show you, we were able to bring much of our
code under test so that when bugs are fixed,
they stayed fix. All right, so just before
I begin, I've been asked to point out this
link here to this talk's wave where you can
ask questions and see notes being taken. All
right, so what did I mean when I said good
unit test? Well, we can probably agree that
these are some properties of good unit tests.
Obviously, we want them to run fast, we want
have good code coverage, and we want to have
both testing granular--code at a granular
but also at an integration level. At Google,
we have this little convention where you probably
heard about it before. We have small test,
medium test, and large tests. Small tests
are the ones that run in, you know--milliseconds
and have no external--they don't depending
on network resource or anything like that.
And we try to have a rule of about 70/20/10
where 70% of our tests are small tests, 20%
are medium, and 10% are large tests. And the
large test--well, a GWTTestCase would count
as a large test. So we don't want--we want
most of our tests not actually be those. All
right, so unfortunately--okay, so testable
code simplifies writing such GWT tests. Now
unfortunately, GWT applications face some
inherent difficulties in the way of achieving
this. And I go through some of them. First
and most importantly is JSNI code. Does everyone
know what JSNI is? Just in case, I'll quickly
explain, JSNI stands for JavaScript Native
Interface. It is JavaScript code which comprises
the lowest building blocks upon which a GWT
app--GWT apps are ultimately based. It is
a necessary bridge for interacting with the
DOM and other browser features. Obviously,
to run code that calls into JSNI requires
having either a browser or some kind of browser
emulator. And GWTTestCase provides this facility.
So any code that we want to test would transitively
depends on the execution of some JSNI requires
sub-classing GWTTestCase. Unfortunately, this
means that most--this implies most of the
GWT Widget and DOM Library and any application-specific
low-level code would need GWTTestCase. So
the problem with GWTTestCase, maybe you guys
probably have known is it's slow and cumbersome
to use. Ultimately for realistic integration
level testing, GWTTestCase and Selenium or
WebDriver based testing is necessary. But
to iterate quickly and easily achieve higher
code coverage, we need to be able to put as
much of our code under plain old fashion,
just lightweight JUnit testing as possible.
Okay, so the next problem is we need to simulate
user interactions. This is further hampered
by a cross-browser event behavior differences.
And I'll talk about that particular point
a bit of depth later. For example, the differences
between key down, key press, mouse down, click
and so forth can be quite insidious between
browsers. So some information--the next point--some
information needed by our programs can only
be properly obtained from a real browser.
For example, if we're asking the DOM about
its size, like how big it actually ended up
being rendered. And frequently, there are
tricky optimizations that we need to perform
that are specific to the web environment.
For example, widget reuse or data structures
optimized for the browser environment or even
on a web browser basis. Often, we need to
defer execution. So for example, by using
DeferredCommand or timer in order to allow
layout to be performed further before further
action or to split up a long running task,
so it doesn't block the UI and other such
reasons. Okay, and so all of these things
can be odds with testing. So writing web applications
is a naturally test hostile environment. And
now that we've got these problems at the front
of my mind, I'd like to go into some patterns
and ideas that we found helpful in our experience
over time. The first thing I'd like to talk
about is the MVP pattern. MVP stands for Model
View Presenter. Now, if you're here last year,
you may remember Ray Ryan's talk about GWT
application architecture that discussed among
other things with the use of MVP in building
the AdWords front-end. It's a great talk.
I encourage you all to check it out. It's
on YouTube. What I'm going to outline here.
I have a few subtle differences but produce
is basically the same. Okay, so I like to
use this little diagram to help explain MVP.
It represents for a conceptual flow of a UI
application. Whether or not it's explicitly
stored, a GUI application has at all time
some kind of presentation state. What you
see displayed in the UI is a function of that
state. So there is some logic, which is at
the top here, but--well, conceptually mapping
at the top here--that maps the state to the
display. And in many cases, if we're just
hacking something up, the display in the state,
you know, would just be conflated together
without any distinction. On the other side
of the loop, the user actions trigger code
that update the presentation stage. Now in
GWT, it's "for display code" over here, that
is the hard to test code. It's a code where
most of our widget and JSNI and on browser
event handles of JSO events and so forth.
And what MVP is particularly good at is isolating
that hard to test code to the greatest extent
possible and while still trying to be a lightweight
pattern. So in MVP, we have a view and we
have a presenter. And the idea is basically
put all the complicated stuff in here, all
the logic in here and leave this to be as
simple as possible, the part that actually
we can't test very well. So it's--and so the
presenter can then communicate to this view
through a very DOM easily implementable interface.
All right, so the goal we're trying to achieve
here is that our JSNI-dependent display code
has kept minimal and trivial and ideally correct
by construction while all our logic is in
testable presenters. Presenters know nothing
of their view implementation as the views--dependents
are injected into the presenters. Contrast
this with MVC, we're roughly speaking until
someone might find, you know, self-aware error
in this. But basically, the thing called the
view confines the whole rendering logic and
display together. So here rather than logic
pushing updates to a simple view interface,
the whole view pulls what it needs from the
presentation or model. And we have a controller
down the bottom that handles UI Events in
a similar fashion. Okay. So here is--just
to, sort of, put this in a different way maybe,
here is an example of an MVP-type hierarchy
for a Foo UI component. We have a FooPresenter
and a FooViewInterface. And the presenter
knows only of and talks only through the view
interface. It doesn't know anything about
what specific implementation is backing it.
In turn, it receives UI gesture events as
a listener of its view and deal with them.
So let's start with a particularly trivial
example for illustrative purposes, an image
thumbnail widget. The capabilities of this
widget are quite simple. It can display an
image and a caption and it accepts clicking
as an actionable UI gesture. So pretty much
all we need in our view interface is exactly
that. Two push methods to set the URL and
the caption and a simple listener interface
that provides all the click events. An application
can choose to do all kinds of complicated
things with this pretty simple building block.
But our application logic is shielded from
the display concerns behind this simple interface.
Now before I go further, I just want to throw
this in here. Everything I'm saying here is
the result of our experiences talking about
things that have worked well for us. I don't
mean for any of this to be prescriptive. So
remember, the goal at the end of a day is
to write clean factored testable code, not
to blindly follow some [INDISTINCT]. So for
us in our experience, MVP helped us a lot
to solve our problems--outlined at the start.
Not all of them, but a lot of them. And I'll
go throughout the solutions as well. And we
found it useful in that it was--we could incrementally
apply it to. We didn't have to rewrite everything
from scratch. Okay, so with that in mind,
I like to outline some general guidelines,
without being prescriptive. I'll be giving
examples shortly. So first off--well, the
whole point is we don't want any transitive
dependency on JSNI in order to run. Otherwise,
we can't--we have to use GWTTestCase so [INDISTINCT]
purpose. Presenter should maintain full presentations
state. That means they don't--now the state
is maintained in the view, they don't have
to ask the view, "Hey view, tell me what currently
I set you to this value or whatever." They
don't have to be recyclable. So this is not
really a rule of thumb. It's more--just something
to point out that in practice if we're going
to be reusing or recycling widgets, we found
in our experience that most of the performance
speed updates from reusing the DOM, not the
presenter which is a very lightweight object
in comparison. So you know, you can keep the
logical at simply by not having to do that.
I'll talk about that a little bit more. And,
you know, presenters can delegate to each
other like using an event bus. It's up to
you. All right, another point is to avoid
the new keyword. I mean obviously, you need
to construct the object somewhere, but in
your presenters, you should, as much as possible,
dependency inject a collaborated so that you
can provide different ones for testing. I'm
not talking about just the views but also
other presenters and so forth. And I encourage
you to try Gin. It's--you probably have heard
of it. It's a dependency injection framework
which is juice for GWT. Okay, now onto the
juicy bit. View interfaces, this is the most
important part. If you designed a good view
interface, everything else will follow. So
they should be satisfied or satisfiable--I
should say--by an obvious trivial implementations.
A default [INDISTINCT] implementation for
testing would, in theory, be machine generatable.
In fact in many cases, it should be possible
for a blank implementation to be a valid one.
So we just have all these blank methods for
many of your interfaces, giving that to a
presenter will--it will still function perfectly,
correctly, and not have any bugs. You can't
[INDISTINCT] all cases, but in many cases,
you can. So what is important? So like this
is not to say that it can't contain logic,
the view implementations. They most certainly
can. And I'll give you some interesting examples
of this, but what is important is that they
are implementable in an obvious trivial way.
The implementation should follow from the
interface. This makes testing easy and accurate.
And in practice, most real widget implementations
of a view interface will, in fact, lack non-trivial
logic. So, the second point is that the view
interfaces should avoid implying a particular
layout or design. They should present an interface
relevant to the application logic we want
to test. This model is good, not just for
testing but, for example, should--would be
good for an app that wants to have both desktop
browser and and mobile browser views or even
for a non-webapp version and application.
Finally, for the last point, avoiding state
getters simplifies the view contract, because
then view implementations aren't required
to maintain any state. So that tries another
one I say about presenters should maintain
full presentation state. I don't mean views
can contain getters, but they shouldn't [INDISTINCT]
state. I'll give you examples of this. So
lack of redundant state avoids potential bugs
and requires less code. There can be some
exceptions, for example [INDISTINCT] but this
kind of thing is not state explicitly maintain
by the view. And so it's not redundant. In
any cases, it's fairly easy to mark out the
tests. All right, in terms of the events that
views in, event center view listener should
be at the correct semantic level. They are
in semantic level. They are too few--that's
why they are too low if they correspond directly
to browser events such as key down and key
press. And this also pushes cross-browser
event pane into our application logic. They
are too high if they correspond to application
logic itself--resulting in [INDISTINCT]. For
example, we didn't create an open image or
show a slideshow in that image thumb in our
example here. We just have a, you know, click.
The user [INDISTINCT] UI gesture. It's because
it's not the image on those to care what happens
when it's clicked. So--and finally, prefer
limiting views to one listener. If you have
more than one, that's probably code [INDISTINCT]
as the view is being made to maintain too
much. So if this is a slide departure from
Ray Ryan's talk where he advocated having
methods like HasHandlers, getButton, HasClickHandlers,
getButton. So where you would get a button
from a view and attach handlers--click handlers
to it like that. There's something wrong with
that. I just personally prefer the more--an
interface where the implementation can be
more blank. And this way, the event listening
is simpler. So at this point, I like to illustrate
with a more real example from my own experience
which illustrates many of the main points.
Google Waves, Wave Panel UI. Now, I'll just
quickly explain the cut down version of the
UI for those unfamiliar so we're on the same
page. Conceptually, you can think of a Wave
as nested threads. Each thread contains are
the GWT switching messages or more threads.
So this is basically what would be stored
in the model so to speak, something like this.
When I want to render it, we want the groups
to show up like this and they're grouped into
a thread as you can see. And note the green
bars on the left, which--note read or unread
status. A clickable blue widget at the bottom
of the blips prompts the user to add a new
blip to the end of a thread like so. And it
can show up differently between blips, prompting
creation of an indented sub-thread like so--with
its own blips. And also, note how the Chrome
around the Blips differs depending on their
place in the UI, for example, whether or not
they have a dashboard up. Okay. So, I think
this is interesting enough. And how would
we structure this using MVP? Well, here's
a subset of the view interfaces taken directly
from the code. The--we have a thread view
and blip view that both extend some blank
view in an interface. The thread view provides
two code variant creation methods for the
addition of new blips and threads within the
parent thread. So if you look at them, they're
quite reminiscent of the DOM-like insert before
method, so you give it the item to insert
before and, you know, if it's not [INDISTINCT]
you know, that kind of thing. Notice how there
is no need for getters here. The view contract
here is--in this particular interface, view
contract is quite straightforward leaving
all the maintenance logic to represent it.
There's no get the nth view out of the--get
the nth child view or anything like that because,
you know, you'd have to actually maintain
a collection and, you know, potentially provide
some kind of non-trivial logic. So the next
one, a blip view contains exactly one indicator
view, the indicator is that blue thing that
you saw. So using UI binder, it is quite natural
and efficient to create both in one go because
this is just a one-to-one correspondence with
them. Just create them all in on go. And so
we have a getter here that's on a state getter.
It's just a little [INDISTINCT] getter that
returns the indicator view that is the child
of that blip. And that's just a getter from
a variable that was constructed by a UI binder
straight out. Or that's more--that's one obvious
implementation of it. And finally, a bunch
of set and forget methods, so one for showing
or hiding the green, read, unread status bar,
and another pair for controlling aspects of
the presentation that depend on the state
and structure of the surrounding thread. So
the show divider and hide divider, those are
the little, the dashboard of things. And the
logic for that can be quite tricky for when
we want to show and hide them because it depends
on the positioning of other blips and threads
nearby. And so this solid interface frees
the view implementation--nothing to worry
about that logic. We can put it all in the
presenter and the view implementation is follow
as trivially from this. So--and I'm not going
to show any really complicated presenter logic
talking to a view because it won't fit on
the slide and the detail such ---really important
to point. I will show you an example of some
lifecycle code which is the boring code, but
it will give you some idea of how to create
views that presenters hook them up and--or
back [INDSTINCT] some abstract although, if
you have one. Okay, so just going through
it quickly. This method, let's say, in our
[INDISTINCT], because an event came from the
server to tell us to do so or builds a UI
gesture that told us to do so. Either way,
our [INDISTINCT] has been updated so that
we now have a new blip. And this is--and we're
given blip. And blip is the model object.
So--oops, that's better. So we--just from
our state, get the view for that current model
object and then we ask the view which is--this
is in a thread. This is in a thread presenter,
so we get our view and we call that createbefore
method. So if this--so we've got the view
for the--for what its next siblings is going
to be or now, we create the new view for this
new presenter we're going to make and then
we created--I mean the tiny top of this should
be blip. So we have some factory which creates
a blip presenter given a view and its mode.
It's just two things we're passing into here.
Now, in reality, the--a presenter might have
many other dependencies but using a factory,
we can carry those a lot and so we don't have
to thread dependencies through seven constructors
all the way down. This is just noble dependency
injection. So I won't go into that in detail.
Okay, and then we return to the blip presenter
so then we do all our state stuff and--yeah.
So that's an--just to give you an idea of
the lifecycle. Okay now, for testing purposes.
What kind of view implementations? Let's go
into actual implementations now. So a testing
mostly obviously is the simplest. You know,
if you use something like Eclipse or an IDE,
you can just say, you know, you can generate
most of the boiler plate implementation for
you. You just say general methods. And if
you have a good view interface, that blank
implementation as I mentioned earlier, will
probably suffice. But obviously, if you want
to record what gets called, you know, you
can use some kind of mocking utility so it
maybe something like [INDISTINCT] whatever
you prefer. And it makes it--with that style
of interface, it makes it a lot easier to
mark because usually--since we only have these
setters, by and large, it's much easier to
mark because we have to say, "When you call
this getter, I return this thing," which then
gives you this other thing so you can attach
the listeners to it and so, you know, this
is quite straightforward. Now, a more real
practical example, obviously, so if we have
a widget that are actually implementing interfaces.
As far as efficiency thing we might want them
to recyclable. So we've had this init reset
recycling pattern where you call init when
the widget is first going to be using, call
reset when you want to stop using it for now,
for many clean-up and then put it back in
a pool of widgets for re-use so we don't keep
[INDISTINCT], you don't--this is actually
a good performance boost. Now, in THE past,
we're now--first, what is now present to logic
and the display logic rules are managed together.
The implementation of init reset required
tricky and also cause a lot of bugs. However,
by--because presenters are, you know, order
of magnitude more lightweight than the actual
widgets, we can--now we've got it separated,
we don't have to reuse our presenters. And,
you know, we can make all the variables final
and this is just one few dimensions to worry
about the testing. And in practice, it turns
out for the widget implementations now [INDISTINCT]
reset because it's just a dumb contract, it's
basically they are the no ups or maybe setting
a couple of things to null and the reset method
is very, it's very simple. Yeah, so next slide.
Here is a more interesting example. So here's
an example where the view implementations
are actually quite non-trivial. So for a large
scrolling UIs such as a wave panel where you
might have hundreds and hundreds of messages,
you need to scroll up and down. It's much
more efficient to render only the visible
widgets. We've had enormous speed improvements
by implementing this. Take it from maybe 30
seconds toward a massive, massive wave to,
you know, virtually instant if we already
had the data loaded from the cell because
we're only rendering the bits we need to render.
And it turns out that most of the performance
by Foo, all the performance been released
all that dumb rendering. So the actual full
tree can be made in terms of the presenters
quite efficiently. And it's--without much
cost but it's the widgets that we need to
optimize. So we can treat this kind of thing
as a view concern. And doing it in some way
has--doing it this way has some advantages.
The presenter code which so far is concerned
only with user interaction logic can remain
clear and uncomplicated. It can remain agnostic
as to whether or not we have this pagination
feature. We don't have to complicate it with
this extra dimension of a, yeah, there's extra
dimension. So, and this is--another advantage
of having a dumb view contract. So to do this,
what we can do is we're going to have the
paging implementation of our view. So, let's
say, we have a FooWidget or a blip widget
or something so if PagingFooView is implementation.
To present a [INDISTINCT], I'm just--put it
there just so you can see where it all fits
in. And then, this implementation delegates
to either a Pojo implementation overview which
is Pojo, you know, playing all jobs or object
just has basically nothing in it. It just
records what methods get called and just sets--sets
just to--when you call a setter, it just sets
a variable to remember that. And there's a
copy into the method to copy all that stuff
into a real widget when we actually want to
page that view in, when it's--when we decided
to come into view and we're going to render
it for real. And in that case, we will have
this delegating next up. Okay, so, how this
is actually works? So, I think, this is called
the state pattern or something--it is more
great complicated obviously, we use--get the
current implementation. So, for example, for
the markUnread method I showed you earlier
in the blip view, we get out info and called
markUnread on it, as simple as that. And for
the Pojo implementation, markUnread would
simply record that in a variable, copy into,
give another view, would call markUnread on
the other one. And for the widget obviously,
we'd use the, you know, the actual pattern
set the grain thing to display whatever. So
as you can see here, the paging logic part
of the view implementation is actually testable.
So, all these blue stuff here is also 100%
JUnit testable. It's still only this bit here,
that's the heart of testing. But since it's
a--the logic in here is still trivial were
all good, right? So, this is an advantage
of having a dumb view contract again. Okay,
so, just little side point, I've mentioned
the word, covariant a few times and I want
to emphasize it. So when I say covariance,
I don't necessarily mean it in the strictest
type [INDISTINCT] sense of the word. For example,
in those create before methods, we accepted
a view, we obviously have to cast it to a
particular widget, you know, to, you know,
in our panel implementation or whatever you're
using to be able to insert it before in the
list. But the important thing is what I mean
is I'm referring to that entire runtime view
structure, like the whole tree with all our
views together is a close universe. I mean,
there's no presenter code can actually construct
the implementations directly. We can't decide
what the implementations we're going to use.
So this allows different groups of collaborating
view implementations to be injected in different
specific contexts. For example, we put enable
and disable paging by using a different group
of view implementations, as simple as that.
Yes. Okay, so, in summary, there's quite of
few things here, but basically, I guess, the
thing I was mentioning most importantly, over
and over again is to have a dumb view contract.
Everything else pretty much follows from there.
You should be in a closed universe and presenters
maintain full presentations state. We don't
want any of our presentation state to be in
the view wherever we can avoid it. Okay, so
that was MVP about, we took only about, you
know, architecture kind of stuff. Using MVP
comes a lot of the problems mentioned at the
start but there are few more that it doesn't
solve for us. So, one of the problems mentioned
at beginning was the need for Web or browser-specific
optimizations. So, a couple of examples I
gave were, we're using widgets as a sort of--once
we think, without example MVP, yup, we just
put that in a view and we're fine. But if
we're doing some kind of JavaScript related
optimization to the actual running of our
JavaScript, you know, if it's run most of
our JavaScript and all the logic codes, so
that's a cross-cutting concerned, and we can't
box that away inside some logic view or something
should be like that. So, one example is GWT's
HashMap and HashSet emulation, it's slow but
it needs to be, I think Joe was mentioning,
talking about in his talk earlier, but this
is a result of having to match the JRE interfaces.
So, for example, bucketing is a necessary
for string or end keys. But just in general,
to implement that interface you need a more
sort of heavy weight collections. So one thing
we can do is write our own Web-optimized collections
data structures with our own interfaces. And
so, that's what we've done. We have so to
compare JSO StringMap, which is a map in string
to something implemented with the JSO, which
is a JavaScript native object, I'll talk about
that a bit later. This is a HashMap. And in
this case, we have a, for a Chrome--this is
just for--this is just a micro-benchmark populating
a map. For a small map, it takes these mini-microseconds,
there are HashMap versus JSO StringMap for
a large map, and then, Firefox--sorry--Safari
and then Firefox. So you can see it's roughly
a factor of two difference in all cases. I/O
has similar results but the numbers are in
order of magnitude larger so the rest of the
graph would look very, you know, part of the
cycle, but yet [INDISTINCT]. So, we have some
efficient data structures like StringMap,
StringSet, NumberMap, IntMap, IdentityMap,
IdentitySet, IntQueue. And let's say you wanted
to write your own data structures such as
these. And then implement interfaces as efficient
designed for efficient JSO implementations.
And then, for unit tests or for server-side
code, we actually want to back those implementations
by regular java.util based implementations.
So we don't actually have to call JSON code
when we're running on the server or when we're
running in the test case. So how we do this?
Okay, well, we could define that collection's
factory interface and dependency injected
everywhere, that's obviously a bit cumbersome
just for collections, right, so, I mean, it's
pretty straightforward. In practice, we don't
really need to provide fake collections with
different logic or anything. So static constructor
method delegating to a singleton factory is
fine and we use "GWT.isScript" to switch between
implementations. "GWT.isScript" tells us if
we're in compiled JavaScript mode versus JVM
mode. So, if--this will turn false if we're
in hosted mode or not using any GWT environment
at all. So, pretty straightforward, so "JsoCollectionFactory"
would have methods like, well, a collection
of [INDISTINCT] StringMap, StringSet and obviously
we just called the JSO version create, et
cetera. For the "JavaCollectionFactory" we,
you know, we would have adopt the HashMap
just to implement those specific interface.
I can go into the details but what we have
specific--why we have different interfaces
and it's mainly to do with iteration. If you
want to have a very efficient data structure,
we need to change--some iteration has to change,
how that works, so we need a different interface,
that sort of important point. Yes, the data
StringSet so on and so forth. So, and then,
we have a factory which is "GWT.isScript"
is JSO1 otherwise it's JavaOne then create
that, okay, very straightforward. Okay now,
sometimes we don't actually want to depend
on GWT at all. I mean, not even have GWT in
any inputs statements. So, for example, in
shared model code that we want to run on the
server, so the solution for now is to use
supersource. I'm sure the GWT guys will come
up with something pretty nifty in the near
future but for now this will works fine. Supersourcing
is basically a--it's like overriding a class
path kind of thing [INDISTINCT]. Instead of
this implementation of this class, you use
this other completely different one. And it's--but
it's the same, you know, packaging, the same
class and everything we just say uses other
one instead. So obviously, that's, you know,
copy paste code sort of duplication. We don't--we
want to minimize that sort of the--the idiom
we use is to have this--just a "platform.java",
that sort of stand the [INDISTINCT] where
we put the platform specific differences as
it where inside here. And so it's--those record
from your--from the collection utils method
where we set up that factory, we just call
"platform.initcollectionsfactory", which will
then call back and set the appropriate one.
And then in the default case, it's just uses
the Java--the regular "java.util" implementation.
But then, in the client, we supersource this,
so for the code that doesn't do any GWT specific
stuff will get the regular one. And the Cloud
will supersource it, and we get--then we have
to switch here. We still need to switch because
the things like hosted mode is still nicer
to use the JavaCollection just because they're
faster when you're actually running in JVM,
you have to cross--the instruction point doesn't
have to cross the JavaScript boundary continually
as your accessing your collections. Okay,
so, another thing I'd like to talk about is
asynchronous logic. This is--some things are
pretty tricky one. So, for example, how would
test it, so you may not know it but I hope
you don't know it. But in GWTTestCase, you
can actually defer the failure or pass status
until a timeout has elapsed. So needless to
say, this is nasty as it makes test flaky
and take even longer to run. It should only
be used when you really need in some integration
text, for some integration test context like
you've actually talk into a real backend.
So, I guess, the obvious solution is to dependency
injects some kind of timer interface, which
we can then fake out under the tests, we can
manually tick the clock asynchronously enough
test but the--but then using the time interface
will get call back and forth as it normally
expected. Okay, so, just an example of it,
this is basically what we use. Now, we have
a schedule method or overloaded versions of
it which is accept the familiar a command
and incremental command interfaces. So there
are few flavors about methods just for convenience
but you can notice that the interface here,
there's no--it's sort of sub-classing type
of API, like timer. It's more of the service
where you schedule tasks. So the advantage
of this solid interface is that it allows
the entire application or pattern of to share
a single time of service, or have a centralized,
different centralized time of services running
at different priorities. It makes easy to
find tune, the running of background logic,
animations rendering. It's an invaluable testing
and debugging feature for logging complex
application. Just a little mention, actually,
I'll mention it later. So, all right, this
is a pretty nasty one, events. So I mentioned
at that start we have a lot of subtle differences
between browsers in terms of KeyDown, KeyPress,
so in particular key events are particular
nasty. So, I'll give you an example of this.
I want to just show you this little testing
[INDISTINCT] here. So, we know that's in a--in
WebKit if I press and hold, you know, you
may notice I get a KeyDown and KeyPress over
time, whereas in Firefox when I press and
hold, I just get a KeyPress for the repeats.
So, you know, if we just listen to all key
events, we would get duplicates in WebKit--yeah,
you have to--I'm sure you--a lot of you would
be familiar with this, you know, you need
some special logic but it's not as simple
as that. I guess quite complicated in terms
of, you know, depending on what key it is
and so on and so forth. And and an ever annoying
differences that "delete" and "full stop"
have the same key code. And the way which
you actually detect which one is which also
differs between browsers, there's lots of
examples such as the delete keys, so just
a--it's a bit of a nasty one. So,
the solution, oops, the solution that we have
is we--to find an interface code signal, just
to make it different, it's basically an event,
same kind of interface. And what you do is
you--we create one from a rawEvent, so from--we
get a raw browser event, we create this signal
thing. And then, this method will return null
if we should just ignore, which means if we're,
for example, if one of us is redundant KeyDown
or KeyPress a base. And then, using that we
can then--it sells, the interface will provide
the difference between things like, you know,
why don't we just get the key code, you'll
know the difference between delete and full
stop and so forth. So, for example, let's
say, this is in one of our dumb widgets. I
know there's a next statement here but it's--I
wouldn't really call this logic. This is more
a decoration of what the events are, where
it's propagating. So, if we hit delete, we
call this "onDelete". If it's an input-type
event, so a full stop would be an input-type
event, we call this ".onUserEditing". Now,
since the signal thing is a nice little interface,
if you want it to be a more complicated logic,
you know, if it belongs in the presenter,
you could just make that part of your listener
interface and call on signal and just pass
that in. So in here, we have all the complicated
logic but actually does all the cross-browser
event normalization. And so what's our test
strategy for this? Well, how would you test
this kind of thing and actually--how would
you test it when you've got--when it's such
a low-level real browser thing? Well, our
strategy is actually to record, again, using
this tool. We can write a little Web JavaScript
that press--that goes in--press a bunch of
keys and we can take all this test data and
actually record it in the big file. And then,
that actually runs in milliseconds, we can
run regression test or that logic. So we can
call these methods like, you know, check that
left as the navigation thing, check that delete
if it actually gives us a delete. And we don't
get redundant events and all that kind of
stuff. And, you know, if a German keyboard
layout, you know, that kind of thing. So,
it's--we can, you know, this is a bug we had
once and now we have a test for it and there's
not going to be bug again. So, it's a small
test, that test always, always cross-browser
event logic. And yeah, I'll just give you
a little demo of that. So here we have an
example, if I hit all stuff and if I hit delete,
you see, it says delete for one and input
for the other. And, you know, if I press and
hold all of it, so it's not giving me a duplicate,
so this is a little test [INDISTINCT]. Now,
you could also write a web driver test to
test this directly like a--kind of a web driver
unit test, which we do as well because it's
good to have lots of tests. Okay, before I
go, I just like to say, well, that stuff I'm
showing like the the signal logic and the
JSO collections and the time and service thing,
we've actually open source that as part of
the wave code. And although I think, it really
belongs more in GWT, so we'll probably try
to move some of that into GWT or as time goes
on. So you can go and get after, write all
that event normalizing logic, it's done. Okay,
so, that hopefully gives you like some ideas
of what interesting sort of long-standard
ways of testing things. So, JavaScriptObject,
I'd just like to talk about--sorry--"SingleJsoImpl".
I don't know who's heard of it, but it's a
pretty useful facility. So, before I explain
that, just a recap of what a JavaScriptObject
is. JavaScriptObject is use as an interface
to raw browser, JavaScriptObject. So for example,
if you have the DOM object or something from
a JavaScript library, the older methods in
a JSO sub-type must be effectively final.
So that means, I mean you can sub-class JavaScriptObjects
but you can't overwrite a specific method.
And one point is that given any JSO and I
call a method on it, I know exactly statically
which method to call. So the syntactic sugar
for static methods. And they cannot be constructed
by Java code because they're the sort of native
object things. Okay. So SingleJsoImpl is a--I
think its a little known facility in GWT.
It's a facility where you can actually have
a JavaScript object being implement--sorry,
implementing an interface. So an interface
method may have at most one implementation
to find within a JSO subtype. So that means,
I mean you can think of it as a compile time
if the compiler sees this interface and a
specific method on it, it knows--still knows
statically which one to actually turn it into.
Because these JSO things, they don't have
any of that runtime dynamic dispatch method
information that is associated with these--with
the Java objects normally. Okay. So I just
like to point out, it has nothing to do with
whether or not the method itself is native,
and so on. So what we can do then is our--for
example, our string map implementation can
be a JSO. So we can have this very efficient
map which is just a pure raw JavaScript object.
There's no wrapper object or anything, and
I put methods to just updating fields on them.
Like so, for example, this is just a helper
that basically sets an exact--give us the
exact key value pair on a JavaScript, raw
JavaScript object escaping it by some optimized
escaping code, obviously. We can do better
than just prefixing it with a colon or whatever.
And yes, so this implements the interface
directly. We don't need wrappers. So this
is a way to--if you get your JSOs to implement
an interface then you can make them, make
your code more testable because you're only
doing for an interface. But it is just as
efficient as if you're using a raw JSO. So
that's the important point. Now for example,
that signal thing--the signal that is map
from--created from an event. It's actually
created. It's still the same event object.
But we just cross-classed it over to this,
and now it implements a nice interface. So
I think that's pretty nifty and then, you
know, get keycode would be "event.as(this).getKeyCode()"
for example and that--it all compiles down
to a property access, right, at runtime. Okay
so, one last little thing I'd want to--I like
to point out, use of Test Harnesses. It's
not really a writing testable code thing.
Well, it kind of helps, but I'd like to advocate
the practice of it. If you're writing some
UI component, it's good to have a little test
[INDISTINCT] which is just for that. I'm sure
a lot of people already to this. But it's
good to have a little test [INDISTINCT] just
for that specific component. It is good for
fast feature development, and all of these
points I've got here. And it does help a little
bit with writing testable code too because
it makes it clear that if you have too many
dependencies, it is hard to write this such
an App. So it helps to keep your things isolated
and clean. I'll try and give a demo of one
of them. So in the, I showed this earlier,
well, the--oops! So for our Wave Editor, I
mean instead of having to load up the whole
client and compile the whole Wave client to
test, you know, as collaborative editing or
something, we can just fire this thing up
and, you know, and notice how it changes,
propagating across the other side. If this
only shows--and it got lots of debugging information
and I'll also like to advocate to the use
for integration testing of webdriver. It's
a very important part about test strategy
for all the stuff I've said about writing,
you know, JUnit small tests and all that.
It's still important to have integration tests.
And having something like this with lots of
places for webdriver to hook into and set
some content or read some information out
which you wouldn't have in your actual applications
is quite useful. So, anyway, so that's about
it. I guess there's lots of things I went
through and I could summarize all of them.
But if there's one take-home point, I would
say its think, "So avoid non-trivial logic
in hard-to-test code." Okay. So, let's start
with questions I guess.
>> I have one here.
>> DANILATOS: Yes.
>> Okay. Can you talk a bit more about webdriver?
>> DANILATOS: About what, sorry?
>> Webdriver.
>> DANILATOS: Oh, talk a little bit more about
webdriver.
>> Yeah, especially the Internet Explorer
driver as opposed to Firefox driver. Do you
use...
>> DANILATOS: As opposed to Firefox driver,
sorry?
>> Yeah. There is an implementation for Internet
Explorer and Firefox.
>> DANILATOS: So...
>> Like in your development for the Wave.
Do you run it in multiple implementations?
So how do you do it on day-to-day basis?
>> DANILATOS: So with--I'm not sure I particularly--fully
understand. So the question was with webdriver,
do we use Firefox driver and IE driver, and
that kind of thing? Yes, we have--I mean webdriver
is an interface. And it is implemented by
various browser specific implementations and
then you write a code which test or says something
like, you know, load up a page, click this
button, type this thing, and check the, [INDISTINCT]
that this element has this content. And you
write it again to that interface and then
the, you know, you can run the same test against
Firefox, IE, and so forth. So it's a very,
actually, something I didn't include in my
talk because it's not released. So I don't
want to make any promises about it. But we've
actually, internally--I might as well mention
it. We've internally implemented a thing we
like to call GWT driver which actually lets
us run our webdriver test which is slow and
cumbersome as a JUnit fast test by loading
up the GWT application, which if you've written
in a testable manner. Well, [INDISTINCT] load
up the GWT application and the webdriver test
in the same JVM and the implementation of
the webdriver interface just drives the application
directly inside the same JVM. So it's actually
pretty nifty but there's a lot more work to
be done on that.
>> Is it Open Source or is it Internal?
>> DANILATOS: It'll probably be release.
>> Okay.
>> DANILATOS: But, yeah, I don't want to make
any promises.
>> Sure. Sure.
>> DANILATOS: That's why I didn't actually
include it in the talk itself.
>> Thank you.
>> DANILATOS: Yep?
>> How does your new architecture--how did
that change your ability to do test driven
development? And what does test driven development
actually look like? I know it was in the description
of the talk, do you test--do you write your
behavior like presenter first or how does
test driven development connect to this sort
of these changes you've made?
>> DANILATOS: Sure. Yes. Yeah, the talk, I
guess, that I may have been slightly misleading.
My talk is more about writing testable code.
But yes, with test driven development, I mean
yep, it's definitely good. I think every developer
might have their own, sort of, style. We don't--at
our workplace, we don't really particularly
enforce what you to do one thing or another
but it's very important to have tests. Some
people find it hard to write a test first
just because they want to try it out, play
around with the code, you know. They haven't
really come up with exactly what the interface
is before, you know. So, I mean yes. Is there
anything more like a specific question about
that? But we definitely don't have...
>> I was just looking for an example of like
what a test driven behavior--test driven development
process would look like that was enabled by
this.
>> DANILATOS: A test driven development process.
That would be...
>> It couldn't otherwise be done. Like what
sort of test? Could you--how could you do
test first with this in a way you couldn't,
if you hadn't, if you'd done MVC instead of
MVP?
>> DANILATOS: I think that's--how could you--the
question was, how could you write test first
in this way that in a way that you couldn't
with other patterns? I think that's--it's
kind of orthogonal, I mean it's more--this,
with these patterns and these ideas that helps
you write different kinds of test. I guess,
so if its not--it doesn't help you write and
test at a different time. It just helps you
write more tests. When you write them, it's
sort of a separate thing up. In my opinion
I think I, yeah.
>> Okay.
>> One of our pinpoints is managing and making
sure that we have a specific tab order of
things that need to be done. Not yet to figure
out a good way to have tab order of the unit
testable. As far as I could tell, Selenium
is not able to--like it doesn't actually record
when you do tabs. It just records the actual
actions. So like if you tabbed through the
entire Google search page and then you did--you
typed something and then you did tab through
it, and then you hit enter. It would just
record the enter. It wouldn't actually record
any of the tabbing. Have you guys come up
with any solutions to that?
>> DANILATOS: So the question is, have we
come up with any solutions particularly with
respect to tabbing with Selenium test. So
you're saying when you tab from one input
field to another it doesn't behave properly
or it doesn't record it?
>> More, like we need to make--I need to make
sure that when we--as we're making all kinds
of changes to our code base, we haven't inserted
some things in somewhere...
>> DANILATOS: Oh, you want to...
>> So that all of a sudden we don't have a
new control somehow hidden like somebody threw
a focus panel some place that's now grabbing
focus.
>> DANILATOS: Okay. So you're asking of, how
do you make sure the tab order didn't get
broken? How do you write a test for maintaining
tab order?
>> Exactly.
>> DANILATOS: Okay. That's a good one actually.
And I think we did have a test for that. Or
maybe we haven't done one yet. But I can't
see why that would actually be a problem because
you can find out which element has focus on
the page, right. So unless there's an actual
deficiency in Selenium, maybe try webdriver
because it's actually--webdriver is the next
Selenium. It's the same interface. It's going
to--it's Selenium 2. It's going to be rechristened
and everything, so webdriver, because it's
not JavaScript sitting in the page. It's actually
a plug-in. So it can do more native kind of
driving at the pages. So that should really
work. And then with webdriver, you can also
call Java--like in your test, you can actually
call JavaScript on the page directly. So you
can set up a little webdriver hooks in your
code. So in your GWT code, for example, native
hooks. So you say "window.webdrivertesthook"
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, you know, equals
some call out to another method. And then
you can return for--you have a test hook that,
for example, returns which element is currently
has focus, or if a certain element--if a specific
element has focus, you know, and then you
could just make your test go tab. The surface
of the element has focus, tab, the surface
of the other element has focus or, you know,
whatever exact logic you particularly want
to test and that should work. I hope that
answers your question.
>> Yeah, it does. Thank you.
>> DANILATOS: Okay.
>> I think you may have just answered my question.
I'm not familiar with webdriver. So you're
saying that's a replacement for Selenium now?
>> DANILATOS: Yes, it is--the path it's headed
is to be Selenium 2. So its--I'm not sure
kind--it's been actively developed, it's--we
use it. It's quite feature complete enough
for us to use. But perhaps it's still not
100% feature parity so that's why it's not
Selenium yet. But it's--the approach is--it
requires more work, obviously, because you
have to write a specific implementation for
every browser. But it also means that the
test is more realistic because it's not JavaScript
simulating, clicking buttons. Its actual buttons
actually being clicked and text actually being
typed, not calling event handlers and putting
stuff in the DOM explicitly.
>> Thanks.
>> DANILATOS: No problem.
>> Yeah. In one of the other presentations,
there were some graphs around. Like continuous
performance measurement. And I was wondering
how you guys do that or like...
>> DANILATOS: Is that with...
>> If that is the way to run Speed Tracer?
>> DANILATOS: Was that [INDISTINCT] Adam Shuck?
>> Yeah.
>> DANILATOS: Yeah. Yeah. That's also the
same team that's what we do.
>> Yeah. Can you talk about how you do that
exactly?
>> DANILATOS: How we actually get those graphs?
>> Yeah.
>> DANILATOS: We have cheap little Windows
laptops that reboot themselves automatically
every so often because, you know, we don't
want the test to sort of degrade over time
because of Windows or whatever. And we just
fires up our--fire up a browser with a webdriver-type
test. Then we perform actions in time to see
how long they take and, you know, the graph
is fuzzy. But it's noticeable. You'll see,
you know, it's like this fuzzy and then it
drops. And then it's fuzzy from there or it
rises up. So, and it's--so that's basically
what we do. We just have a bunch of those
continually synching to the tip building and
running--well, we don't obviously build with
the small laptops. The small laptops connect
to a server. And we see how fast it takes--how
long it takes for things to load or, you know,
whatever it is that we're testing. Is that
the answer to your question?
>> Where did you get the timing information
from--is that from Speed Tracer or some--or
how do you...?
>> DANILATOS: I don't think we use Speed Tracer
for the automated time. We just actually record
the time it takes in the browser or in the
test. I'm not sure of the details but I think
it's basically just that. Question was how
do we actually record the timing? Yes?
>> I'm curious. Is there a way you have to
test the UI code in a way where the--non-graphically--where
the unit test start up time takes less than
a couple or a few seconds?
>> DANILATOS: Oh, absolutely. If you--sorry,
the UI code itself, the heart of the test.
>> The UI code in a non-graphical test.
>> DANILATOS: So do you mean not the regular
test that we would have, say, for presentors.
But you want to actually test the widget implementations
of use?
>> Right.
>> DANILATOS: Okay. So well, the idea is,
with based in MVP, if you have a DOM view
contract. Then your widget implementation
is so trivial that literally, you know, if
it's set this, your implementation is set
this other line of code. I mean, that's something
that's quite unlikely to break. And if it's
going to break, you're going to notice it
immediately when you just load up your app.
It's not like a subtle bug that it's going
to regress later and it's going to be hard
to detect. So the whole point is to actually
obviate the need for even writing that test
in the first place. Now it's too good to have
integration test that sort of run through
and, you know, make sure everything hooks
up together. And in terms of actually making
that run faster, there is a way. And what
you can do is--and this is one of the things
we're doing for GWT, this GWT writer thing
I talked about, is you can use a custom--it's
a bit of a hack, but you can use a custom
class loader to replace anything that runs
JSNI. And for example, you can replace elements
with some other different implementation of
elements that's in Java. Then it can actually
run pretty fast. However, at the end of the
day if you want a real true test, you're going
to need a real true browser. So it depends
on how realistic you want to get. And I would
say if you write your code in a--with MVP
in that style on the scale of, you know, non-realistic
to fully realistic. It's almost all the way
at fully realistic. Because the rest of the
bit that you haven't tested is quite minimal,
and then if you going to do with effort just
to test that one little bit further and you
want it to be fast. And if you want it to
be fast, you're probably not going to be loading
up a real browser. You're going to do some--you're
going to cut some kind of corner. So it's
still not going to be a hundred percent realistic
and I mean do you really care about that last
little bit this much? You may as well just
have lots of good, you know, tests on your
presentors. Put all your logic in a testable
manner. And then have some integration test
to test the whole thing through.
>> Okay.
>> DANILATOS: Okay. Oh, yes, you have a question?
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> DANILATOS: So the widgets you mean?
>> Yes.
>> DANILATOS: So the question was with our
coverage reporting, do we tell the coverage
reporter to ignore the fact that we're not
covering the widget code? We don't currently.
But--I mean, you know, does it really matter?
Yeah. So, we do have a lot of GWTTestCases
don't get me wrong. We have heaps and heaps
of GWTTestCases. And also this code does get
covered with webdriver as well. It's hard
to get coverage reports for that. We're going
to work on finding a way to do that. But,
you know, it could--[INDISTINCT] would be
actually run it against hosted model something
and get coverage that way or maybe find some
way through the JavaScript to get coverage.
But it's not a super high priority. Yes?
>> I have a question. So if you get the MVP
test and then a webdriver test, which is what
I've got now. I don't--actually, I have very
many GWTTestCases. Do you think that that's
fine that the webdriver can basically replace
those or where do you see who are still using
GWTTestCases if you've got webdriver in the
picture?
>> DANILATOS: So the question is, I mean,
if you got all these MVP tests and then--so
you, in particular, don't have any GWTTestCases?
>> Right.
>> DANILATOS: Yes. So we have all of these
MVP test cases and then webdriver to do the
integration testing. And there's no GWTTestCase
at all. I mean if that's working for you then
great. I mean you don't have to wait for your
GWTTestCases to run. GWTTestCase--I mean I
would see GWTTestCases are heavy integration
level testing tool similar to webdriver, not
quite as heavy. A GWTTestCase will probably
be faster than a webdriver test. But I see
it as somewhere in between the two. But if
you've got, you know--if your app is reliable
and you've got good coverage and you're happy
with that and then whatever works. I guess.
I wouldn't say "No, you must have GWTTestCase."
Okay. Time up. Thanks everyone.